[Music]
why don't we go next to nico from new
hampshire nico welcome
hi david how are you i'm doing well
so um
i'm a phd student in clinical psychology
and actually i care a great deal about
empathy
with the midterm elections on the
horizon my question for you is why do
you think modern politicians refuse to
empathize with each other
why do they refuse to empathize you know
i don't know if refuse is necessarily
the right word i mean i think
they don't empathize with each other but
for for some of these people they seem
unable to imagine what it would be like
to be in the position of someone else
it's it seems like they they're just
unable to do it so i don't know if
refuse is the right word
yeah perhaps in the public setting in
the public eye as opposed to outside
well i do think that in that sense
there's probably some belief maybe it's
it's accurate even that if you empathize
with the other side that you're seeding
ground to them rhetorically so that then
all of a sudden you end up backed into a
corner i don't know i mean i'm thinking
out loud i can understand how they might
think that
okay yeah i was kind of having a similar
mindset about it it kind of a fear of
looking weak or conceding so i i agree
with that another question is
why do you think seemingly basic amounts
of empathy that you'd think would be
within all people uh which i'd like to
think is common um they're not reflected
in our laws
can you give me an example of that
well uh we could look at the abortion
laws at this moment and that would go on
the
context of um
you know morality and that's a whole
other discussion but in reality of
wanting to help others
seeing that people are struggling in
certain areas and that that's not
prioritizing normal yeah i mean i think
that's the case in some of these
anti-abortion states but but that so
you're saying there are state-level
abortion laws that show no empathy
right yeah i agree with that i agree
with that i mean i think that's the way
that they're designed you've got people
writing these laws who sometimes who
have a very black white or sometimes
religiously oriented oriented view about
abortion
and they
what you and i would call empathy they
would call uh they would they might call
sin or immorality and so if that you're
not going to be you're not going to
willingly put that stuff into a law
okay well thank you for answering those
questions
have a good rest of your day all right
and that was nico from new haven i
incorrectly said new hampshire but that
was nico from new haven let's take a
very quick break if you're holding don't
hang up because we're going right back
to the phones in a moment